ladies and gentlemen uh Navy diver
current Navy diver ex essentially Navy
steel from Australia double UT
conservationist shark diver uh shark
weak shark weak star uh host
motivational
speaker it's Shark Week up in fining kid
Studios yeah we have our own Shark Week
I thought Paul Chanel yeah Paul deller
is diving in Sydney Bay where you can
see the opera house and let's have him
tell the story I know I'm just setting
it up don't tell him pleas don't tell
the story but I want to go let's have
him set it up please don't ruin this it
funny I was like let me explain how I
feel oh my God now take it my man what
exactly just give you told the story a
thousand times literally 1,000 times
tell us for our listeners probably more
probably more um so while I was at work
one day in February 2009 doing a
counterterrorism exercise I was in the
water um you like you said you can see
the Harbor Bridge you can see the Sydney
Opera House house so this a very popular
spot and we dive and work there all the
time so I swam and dive there thousands
of times and I was on the surface on my
back with a a very thin wet suit on and
a pair of fins and while I was in the
water after probably only four or 5
minutes a bull shark came up from
underneath me grabbed me by the back of
the leg and the hand on my right side
all in one bite and decided that I was
breakfast and just started tearing me to
pieces and you you didn't see at all
right it was totally unexpected yeah I
was looking the other direction and I
felt something hit me and it didn't hurt
at that point so I turned around
thinking the guys in the boat got a
little bit too close and then you turn
around and you see your worst nightmare
attached to you and you kind of don't
know what to do and what did your
natural reactions kick into fight
because obviously I mean you're a tough
guy Navy SEAL basically of Australia so
your natural reactions to fight I assume
yeah after a second of going is this
real life
uh you think you know you think okay
I've seen the crocodile hunter I'll jab
it in the eyeball but it had my hand in
its mouth so I couldn't use it so I
tried to do it with my left hand but I
couldn't reach I tried to punch it in
the head that didn't work I think I just
pissed it off and then it started
shaking me like sharks do took me
underwater kept shaking me um when a
bull shark grabs something it uses its
top teeth first to grab on and then the
jaw is actually movable so when they
shake the teeth Act together as a so oh
that's nice so while it was shaking me
it's soaring the flesh out of my body
it's a [__] day at work yeah it's a [__]
day at work it's a [__] just that's an
understat but like on on you see these
shark experts are like yeah you see a
shark man you just punch the thing you
just punching the nose tag side oh yeah
that easy yeah I tried that one didn't
work yeah oh why because everything
tries to do that to him and he has
protectors over his eyes or his eyeballs
are hard as [__] like Marbles and it
does not F it's also probably 1,000 PB
of muscle right yeah yeah this thing was
9t I'm I'm 6ot so it's got 3T of muscle
on me and they're huge they're so strong
designed to swim around in the water
just a body of muscle and when they grab
you and they start shaking you realize
how useless and Powerless you actually
are yeah it's killing you with its face
you you realize man really isn't [__] in
the grand scheme of things yeah we have
guns and Technology but if it comes down
to it mother nature sharks beers you're
screwed there was a conserv to
Yellowstone has said look this is not a
park a theme park there are there are
elements in this park that don't give
two shits if you live or die you've just
got to understand how to navigate but I
when I was watching some of your stuff
they don't really tell you what to do
and maybe there is nothing to do giant
Marine Mammal animal grabs you I've
watched all his interviews and they like
so if I'm going to attack by a shark
what should I do blint you [__]
idiots nothing you're in his you're in
his land what do you punch him in the I
st okay yeah let me try I'm sure that's
worked by accident where people have
been like ah and the shark like that's a
human well they wouldn't have just
created out of nowhere I guess but it's
been done it's happened I guess it's the
only thing you can do it's nothing's
100% didn't work for me but well so
we're one for one it's our 30 so far did
was there a point when he dragged you
under water we like oh this is it oh
yeah what a way totally though so it
lasted about 8 to 10 seconds the footage
is on YouTube you can watch it um they
were recording it as part of the
exercise and then they a TV show in
Australia ended up getting that footage
from the Navy so it's on YouTube you can
actually watch it but at about five or
six seconds in I'm thinking this is it
I'm not going home today I'm going to
die right now cuz you could easily Blood
Out yeah yeah well it missed my femoral
artery by a couple of millimeters if it
even nicked that artery I would have
bled out and died before I was even out
of the water all time yeah and as it was
when the lads in the safety boat got to
me and took me to the warf um by by the
time they got me to the warf or the pier
you guys call it I think um the boat was
an inch deep in my blood my chief who
took control of the situation already
thought that I was dead so one of the
guys had to stick his hand inside my leg
and pinch closed an artery with his
fingers to keep me alive first of all
good thing that you were with guys who
kind of knew what to do in that
situation to an extent at least yeah
really but you guys I'm I'm I you guys
don't go over what happens if some one
of you one of the guys in your unit or
platoon attacked by a but shark right
that's not protocol we do a dive brief
before we get in the water for every
dive we didn't that day because it
wasn't actually diving we were just
surface swimming but there's a section
in the dive brief that says uh dma which
stands for dangerous marine animals and
the only thing it says is if you
encounter dma exercise caution ah thanks
Dr no help thanks for that pamp I love
when they say that [__] they say the
thing about a bear if you hear a bear uh
chances are it is is a bear it's not
just some dog so exercise
caution uhhuh hey so the thing that
really saved my life was um was the
military training of how to stay calm
Under Pressure you know I I popped to
the surface with my hand gone my
hamstring missing and at that point I
didn't know what damage was done to my
leg but I started swimming for the
safety boat and when I took my arm out
of the water I could see my hand was
gone and my medical training instantly
kicked in and said okay keep that wound
above your heart plus from watching
Shark where I knew that sharks can
detect one drop of blood in 10,000
leagues of ocean or whatever so I didn't
want the blood going into the water so I
raised my arm above my heart and started
swimming for the safety boat my medical
training told me that if I looked at the
injury in my leg and it was horrific
then I could go into shock and I'd die
so I didn't I didn't even bother looking
at it I just focused on talking to my
friends staying calm so all that stuff
came into play wow so in other words you
take your attention off your injury and
put it somewhere else as much as you can
yeah sorry that's
amazing that would be your phone down
here we've only done 200 shows he's been
show business for 20
years great story though
man um lost my place now we're exactly
but but that that's festing when you
deal with shock I've heard that before
from combat um veterans and people who
are trained that way so so in Vietnam
what they found was a lot of the Viet
Kong would not go in shock even though
they have horrific injuries because they
were putting their attention somewhere
else a lot of Americans would get shot
and because in many ways just our
culture holy [__] I've been shot they
would focus on that and go in a shock I
think yours is more of holy [__] I need
to survive and get to the boat yeah I
you don't have time I didn't even think
I was going to make it to the boat I
didn't think I was going to get out of
the water at all and even when I was
swimming to the boat but with one hand
and one leg I'm thinking I'm not going
to make it this shark's going to come
back any second is going to grab me by
the other leg take me under water and
I'm going to die cuz I'm running out of
air I'm running out of blood I'm running
out of energy I'm swimming with one hand
because I can't operate my leg and I'm
just thinking this is it I'm stuffed I'm
going I'm going to go down right now but
you got to stay calm and you focus on
one thing at a time then it was get to
the boat and then it was you know as
soon as I got into the boat I was so
relieved at not being eaten anymore I
relaxed and and passed out and my buddy
sprang on top of me and thought he knew
that I was going into cardiac arrest so
he stimulated my heart oh so you were
going into cardiac arrest yeah I passed
out well that's what he thought anyway I
don't know I don't know to tell whether
my heart's stopping or not but he jumped
on top of me and started pummeling me in
the chest to stimulate my heart or make
me back up and that worked damn but then
I wake up and I look over and my hands
gone mangled and bitten off by a shark
and I look up and my mate tommo is
beating the [__] out of me and I'm just
thinking today sucks that's a rough day
in the off today suck can I ask you this
is I've always wondered and and it's
probably a question that's hard to
answer but I've always wondered what
people go through horrific or traumatic
catastrophic situations in live does
this has this I know I'm sure it's
changed you in how you approach life and
how you approach just everyday
challenges but has it in any way made
you less afraid of death or totally it
has there is I have no fear of death
anymore wow it at all like there there
is when you come that close to death you
realize there's nothing left to be
afraid of and even death isn't that
scary like when when you're you feel
like you're 3 seconds away from taking
your life Last Breath there's a calm
that washes over you and part of that
for me was knowing that I had no regrets
I had a clear conscience and I was ready
to go that didn't actually happen yeah
it was I'm not getting out of here I'm
going to die right now and a calm comes
on over you and then I didn't die and
there's just nothing left to be afraid
of that was my worst nightmare public
speaking public that and you're doing
both now yeah you got do both how weird
is that now I make shark documentaries
reason I do motivational
speaking this is what you couldn't make
this [__] up no you can't if Hollywood
wrote the story like that's some
[__] that would never happen um
what's weird to me is I wonder why the
shark let you go and didn't finish the
job hopefully it was choking to death on
your h on his huge hamstring yeah so I
think the fact that it you know it it
actually removed a huge chunk of my leg
um and I guess it was either full or it
was while it was eating it it worked out
that I'm not what it normally eats it
didn't like it so it just took off and
so you go through all this you're in the
hospital and it it's and I'm sure you're
getting a bunch of media attention stuff
like that it's alarming blah blah blah
but then when you get out of the
hospital and you're back at your bed in
your bedroom and you're missing an arm
missing a leg I'm sure it hits you then
because all that wears off all the
excitement yeah you're missing an arm
and a leg life's never going to be the
same yeah that first night at home funny
should say that too the first night at
home was the worst because for nine
weeks I was in hospital and you have
constant visitors and you've got the
doctors coming in the nurses coming to
check on you all the time and you're
sort of distracted plus you're drugged
to the eyeballs on the best drugs um and
then you go home and yourself medicating
and that first night I sat on the edge
of my bed and there was no more visitors
no friends no doctors none of that stuff
it's just you for the first time and I
looked down at myself and for the first
time in my life I saw a disabled person
and my heart just broke after being so
physically gifted and that was
everything I relied on because I'm not
the I'm not the smartest guy I got by
and I got through my military career by
being able to push my body and my mind
beyond the limits yeah so that so that
night you just started for the I started
crying man just crying it was too much I
was thinking how am I going to live the
rest of my life like this what what job
am I possibly going to be able to have I
can't go back to the job that I love how
am I going to slide down a rope out of a
hel helicopter with one hand you know
how how am I going to go diving how am I
going to do normal everyday things like
drive a car and all that [__] is it safe
to say there are suicidal thoughts it
wasn't really an option like stuff like
that Creeps in but I never seriously
considered it just because maybe not
suicide or do you wish the shark would
have finished the job oh yeah oh when
especially when I was in hospital and
the day after I had my leg removed uh
the the pain management team couldn't
get my pain under control and I laid in
my bed for 20 hours crying and rolling
from side to side in my bed wishing that
the shark had where was the pain it was
just the nerves I guess whole body there
there was no one spot just because it
overrides your whole central nervous
system so everything was hurting plus I
was on ketamine if anyone who knows
anything about ketamine or Special K
that can really mess with your brain and
put you into a khole I was having um I
was hallucinating I thought I'd got died
and gone to Hell uh I could hear
everyone around me in the visiting area
visiting other patients and I I just
laid in my hospital bed rolling from
side to side crying wishing that the
shark had killed me when did it when did
the pain go away after 20
hours why did it go away uh I'm not
entirely sure but they were able to give
you the right cocktail of drugs it must
have been yeah do you still feel
physical pain from your injury somewhat
I have um you might have heard of the
term phantom phantom Lim pain yeah so
that's real oh yeah it's yeah it's bad
too and I don't have the bad stuff all
the time there's two there's two
different types so there's phantom pain
and there's what I call Phantom
sensation and the phantom pain is really
bad uh I get an electrical bolt all the
way from the top of my hip all the way
down into the foot that's not even there
which is weird as [__] and it feels like
you're being electrocuted it hurts so
much and sometimes it's maybe I'll get
one in 2 months and then say I'll get 20
20 hours of it every every 20 seconds
would you it's like lighting like
electric yeah yeah it's like being
electrocuted and the Hand it's like
being stung by a bee over and over and
over and over again once again it might
be one time in 6 months and then I might
get it for 24 hours so let's go back to
the night when you're crying you're at
home you're getting back to regular
civilian life I what point are you like
[__] this I'm still this badass um and
not only am I not afraid of sharks but
I'm start helping him then I'm going to
land a gig on Discovery Channel oh and
I'm also going to do motivational
speaking cuz I'm terrified of that well
how's that how do you even get to that
point where where's this middle part
where you just pick up your lunch box
and get back to work no I just woke up
and said that's it I'm going on shock
like I I tried that and they're like no
you're not [__] well you look like a
giant seal you should see him in the
waves legs together he's doing like he's
doing that dolphin Bob with his by his
hips
after homeboy you look like a giant seal
there are great whites out there that
are just H hungry so you're going
through all this I'm sure everyone's
feeling sorry for you media and then
yeah like how do how do you get to that
point well the main thing after I woke
up was uh worrying about my career and
that was the first step I needed to know
that I could have some value and purpose
I needed my job you know that's what
gets us up out of bed every day we got
value we have purpose we're busy our
lives are full so I needed to know that
I could have some of that just to get
the motivation to go on with life um and
I wanted to stay in my job and luckily
for me the chief of the Navy in
Australia said as long as I wanted a job
in the Navy I would have one I don't
think he realized I wanted my old job
back but I did so that was the goal and
that was an Impossible Dream you know
you know no one's going to look at you
laying in a bed with one leg and one
hand to go oh yeah he could definitely
be be a clearance diver again and I'm
not even sure I believed it but what I
did was set small achievable goals you
know get up earlier get off the drugs
eat better focus on the next step learn
to walk get a leg and then learn to walk
um so it was a one step at a time
exactly right and sometimes that first
step is the hardest because you you
don't have any motivation to drive you
on but as soon as you make that first
step and it doesn't matter how big or
small that is at all just as long as you
take it and then you can look back and
go oh [__] you know I've done something
here all right well what what else can I
do so I started 2 days after I had my
leg chopped off and I was laying in my
hospital bed thinking okay how did how
did I get here to begin with because I
wasn't always you know I was an Army
paratrooper at 23 and then I changed the
Navy at 28 but I wasn't always that way
I was a a weed smoking stealing fighting
drinking Punk uh so I thought back to
what helped me get to become this person
and it was PT physical training that's
what gave me my drive of my focus so I
thought I why would I stop you know
something that's worked in the past and
two days after I had my leg chopped off
the surgeon came into my room and found
me doing one arm chinups on the bar
above my bed picture yeah just and that
that wasn't try and be impressive uh
even though I was pretty impressed in
myself um that was just keeping your
head I just needed to take a first step
you know I couldn't even go to the
toilet by myself but I could lift myself
up repeatedly so I just did that you
know stay busy keep your mind focused
learn about your situation you I had to
learn all about Prosthetics and what was
out there what was coming next what
YouTube clips of paralympic athletes and
dudes with no legs climbing mountains
and the more research I did the more I
realized that if these people can do it
then there's no reason that I can't do
it you know my life is not over if if I
get the right tools I can do any job
that I need to be able to do so that
that was the process and it it took a
really long time how how long we talking
so I had to go through three more
surgeries as well because when your
bones break and they put pin them
together the bones lay down down this
like concrete uh calcium deposit yeah to
help the bone heal stay together while
it's regrowing but I didn't have a
second bone for it to grow to so I was
laying down this bone concrete and
creating Spurs and they were digging
into my flesh so I I had to have those
removed three times over about two years
so I had to keep going for surgery
learning to walk again going for surgery
learn to walk again so it was a slow
process but at the same time I was just
because I couldn't walk didn't mean I
wasn't going to progress in other areas
is you know I'd get on my crutches and
I'd go to the gym and I work my upper
body or I'd go to work and I'd try and
learn the courses that I'm going to be
teaching things like that there's always
something you can do what's the name of
your book no time for fear how long has
it been out uh it's been out for I think
three and a half years now and and that
that was there a book you read before
that that helped you more than any other
book was there somebody was there
anybody who you listen to that put
things in perspective that gave you
mental tools or had you already kind of
been exposed was there any authors that
also got bit by shark and help you out I
mean it's kind of question he's kind of
you know I mean you're right I mean in
other words you can relate to that I'm
not going to read [__] Shakespeare
when a shark bit my arm and leg I'm GNA
do my own thing you don't kind had to
write your own book right I mean yeah
look I had I have some great friends I
have some very clever friends that
helped me out with some good advice and
one of them said to me one day you I was
feeling pretty bad and you said look
don't feel bad about feeling bad there's
nothing wrong with that it's a natural
human emotion feel bad just feel bad
identify why you feel bad and then fix
it or move on don't let it ruin your day
your week or your whole life so that's
something that St like kind of be be
allow yourself to feel human about this
acknowledge it but then you got to get
going like you can't be a habit or
lifestyle feeling sorry for yourself
exactly right so there wasn't really any
books um obviously there's the movie
that was surprisingly just on TV the
other day when I was uh hanging at my
friend's place at Imperial Beach um Men
of Honor about you know CU Gooding J
plays uh K Basher the Navy diver that
gets his leg taken off you know so I
watched that about a thousand times
movies are important story there's also
a book that helped me with my mindset
which is um the Peaceful Warrior by Dan
milman I've heard about that really
really good book um just sort of changed
my mindset about a lot of things like
what do you mean like me about feeling
feeling sorry for yourself and you know
focusing internally instead of looking
externally at what you can achieve and
that's actually been my greatest sense
of of Happiness not trying to provide
for myself you know I I made I made so
much money doing this motivational
speaking more than I ever thought I
could possibly do and doing TV and stuff
um and I could buy myself a nice car and
I can buy a house and all that stuff but
I don't need it you know you know what
makes me happiest doing things for other
people so putting your attention over
there again not not not on your but we
you know Paul we live in I always talk
about this a culture in a society that
that really does Focus on it's you know
you're you're allowed to really make
yourself the center of the entire
universe and that's the wrong way to go
about it right we're also an
entertainment be we're surrounded we're
surrounded by it yeah so I our our views
a little skewed because we're surrounded
by entertainers where it's about them
yeah it's and and that is one of the
things that I I only spent two two weeks
um in Afghanistan doing some stand up
for the troops and one of the things I I
it was very interesting because the big
thing I took away it took away a lot but
when you're in the military and you're
in a war zone it's always about the
other guy and the other people it's
always about your company your core it's
always about your your duty and you come
last in that equation and I have to say
it was so and it was so refreshing to be
around and I realized that I and I my
culture that I was living in in Los
Angeles was very much the opposite yeah
still it was a good it was a good
perspective check man you know and it's
like it's like the feeling bad thing
it's you know it's not a bad thing
people love to be loved I love to be
loved I like to have a little bit of
attention as well but when it becomes
your sole source of Happiness you're
going to fail sure you know what kind of
work are you doing with sharks now
because I think most people if a shark
changed their life in the way it changed
yours they'd almost like [__] it and go
on this revenge tour but you're kind of
surprisingly enough most people don't do
that most people people who are in the
water who have been bitten by a shark
understand that they were in the shark's
domain they don't hold a grudge you know
you're still pissed off you're like you
know you get upset about this bloody
animal changing your life and nearly
killing you but you realize that's the
risk you take that's what people that
exist on the coastlines and spend lots
of time in the water that's the mindset
we have so no one you no one goes out
trying to kill sharks after they've been
bitten as far as I'm aware anyway but uh
yeah what my thing is at what point were
you like all right I need to bring
attention to this beautiful animal that
some would say ruined my life at look
that that happened pretty slowly um
being the only clearance dver in
Australia that's ever been attacked by a
shark and the first person that's been
attacked by a shark in Sydney Harbor in
60 years there was a lot of media
attention so uh I had the opportunity to
learn a lot about sharks by hanging
around people that were shark experts
and scientists and do interviews and
spend time on Shark Week you know I've
met some of the the most renowned shark
cinematographers and experts in the
world so all I do is just try and absorb
this information because the first time
that I got into the water with a shark
after the shark attack you know that was
my first time what kind of shark did you
get in there we I did an aquarium swim
twice with uh I think you guys call him
sand tigers oh yeah they have all the
teeth but they're not that dangerous
right I couldn't look at the face
initially I bet not dangerous correct
they're not dangerous and then I went to
uh fij and I dove with bull sharks and
the bull sharks hey man yeah like so
many so many sharks you can barely see
the water not only did I dive with them
but the guy who who does it taught me
he's an ex South African clearance dver
and he taught me how to hand feed the
bull sharks so I ended up is he the guy
who puts them in taric no no that's out
of the Bahamas as far as I'm aware okay
so so here's my question about how do
the experts know was a bull shark and
not a great white by the bites in my leg
and the wet so by the teeth marks I got
you um you need to watch some Shark Week
time yeah well I know a lot about bulls
I know bull sharks I think attack more
people but you know we were talking
about this brenon was saying they say
well your chances of a shark attack are
one in a million your odds I was unless
you're in the water a lot cuz like if
like your odds are going to be higher
cuz your job requires you be in the
water all the time so when they say
you're more likely to get to to die by
pig that's not true if I'm on the farm
all the time maybe but you got to take
those odds in consider you're more
likely to die in a car accident on the
white of the beach well yeah because
you're in the car way more than you are
in the beach yeah if you're in the water
your odds are so your odds are higher
than mine yeah exactly right exactly
right so that one in a million doesn't
count for you that's for cuz the the
person in Iowa was like hell yeah one in
a million
well of they really don't include those
OP I wonder what these stats would be on
if you got the middle of the ocean and
you swam 10 miles in the middle of the
ocean I wonder what that would do to
your depends what part of the ocean
people do it yeah it depends on part of
the ocean it depends on the time of year
depends on if there's fish around
morning dust Dawn yeah so the the same
week that I got B this I don't need to
no I'm saying no they they go over all
stuff yeah yeah it all depends they
literally cover I mean how long Shark
Week been
around 28 years they they've answered
every question you can imagine in a cage
and all it's nuts yeah they're
incredible animals I didn't fully
appreciate them until I was actually in
the water with them and when you're in
the water with them I'm not talking
about great whites in a cage where
they're blooding and baiting them but
when you're swimming with 15 bull sharks
20 nurse sharks you got 30 reef sharks
all around you and you think in your
brain when you're on the surface this is
going to be terrifying but when you're
down there watching it it's so amazing
and you don't feel threatened at all m
why were why were those bull sharks not
dangerous in that
environment um well they're not always
dangerous anyway um they'd been doing
this for 16 years and it was a dead Reef
they went out there they recreated and
reinvigorated this reef and the Sharks
weren't even there at that point so they
had to attract the fish the fish
attracted the Sharks eventually and then
it was another 6 months before they
could even get the sharks in close
enough to try and feed them so this was
a really long slow process and they
built up a a recognition and almost a
friendship I think is that dangerous
with because I I see a lot of kind of
criticism with the shark diving when
they Chum the water and then the Sharks
mainly great whites associate uh
chumming and blood with humans cuz then
they see humans so when you guys are
trying to attract these bull sharks
whatever and you're feeding the Sharks
don't you think that's kind of that's
what that's what I thought as well but I
talked to Brandon who'd been doing it
all this time he said that no one gets
bitten by sharks there the only guys
that get bitten are the are the natives
in fij that go out there at night spear
fishing oh cuz they hit the fish blood
and Shar so they're the only guys that
get my friend Ken was is a long-distance
swimmer and he he went to a while back
off Catalina this guy got in big trouble
because he was chumming water and
getting monster great whites to come up
but the problem was Surfers were a mile
away oh man and it was a big big issue
right I mean this guy got you know they
tried to find him and he bought he
fought it but it was he was bringing
tourist boats out there and Chum in the
water and getting these great whites to
come up see I want to see that of course
you do and so do I but you can't do that
when you got Surfers pretty amazing but
you're right yeah so now my buddy
Ken he uh Gets In The Water he does a
swim he gets in the water at Catalina at
11: at night 11:00 p.m. and swims he
freestyles to Santa Monica he gets the
the shore at 7 in the morning or 6:00 in
the morning Dusk and Dawn and I'm like
bro you swam in those Waters and we know
there are great whites we know there are
great whites all in that area and you
swam at night on the surface split split
splashing away uh and of course you know
he was like well you don't really think
about it well I do on top of that they
had the the only thing I can think about
they had the lights the boat the the
boat had lights on he said turn the
lights off they go you sure he goes yeah
because the guy said the problem with
lights is that the squid come up and
when the squid come up the Sharks come
up so let's go ahead and not have I just
I can't imagine did you did you see the
L that the the it was the world record I
think or she's one of the first people s
swim from I want to say Florida to Cuba
but she got Flack because she had a
little bit of a barrier around her just
in case sharks people like [__] man
you got shark protectors like hey man
and they're jellyfish like the box
jellyfish those things will kill you mm
yeah he all yeah for sure your friend
was he suicidal that's crazy it is right
I would never do that but then they do
it at Bondi every day I've been living
down at Bondi Beach in Sydney for the
past 3 months and they do the old people
and young people do it every morning
swim from head to head couple of
kilometers every morning and no one ever
gets attacked yet there's great white
sharks there all the time well I saw a
quote by you said If people really knew
how many sharks were around in the water
as close as everyone's swimming no when
would go in the water is that true oh
yeah yeah they're around us all the time
you think about when you're sitting on
the water in your on your surfboard um
you can Envision this even if you're not
a surfer you're sitting on the water the
sun's beating down reflecting off the
waves you can't see more than a couple
of feet away from you unless maybe
you're in Hawaii and the water is
crystal clear or something like that but
you do not know what is around you there
are so many sharks following the
coastline chasing the food they're not
complex creatures that we don't
understand a lot about them but what
what do we know they eat they mate and
they pop so they're just following the
food they're following the the mating
rituals going to the places where they
made and they pop they're around us all
the time they follow the coastline and
they they say down here especially I
think from San Diego all the way to San
Francisco they call it the part of the
triangle the shark triangle where
there's just great whites everywhere but
however having said all that I guess one
of the reasons great whites are not
attacking people as much is because from
an evolutionary P perspective they're
not they didn't evolve to eat human so a
human looks are alien it doesn't look
like their food source right that's
right fish and and seals are what their
food source is yeah well attacks are
actually up in California from 1960 is
that true not deaths attacks yeah yeah
and and that's why it's
just well there it goes although we
haven't had a great white attack in
Malibu or Santa Monica I think ever
right really ever I don't think there's
ever been uh an attack on a human being
in Santa Monica Venice uh Marina delw
there has been in San Diego that's
giving me some confidence for when I go
out surfing now yeah you're good you are
you surfing you're also a surfer
yeah I saw a picture you surfing with
it's nuts man crazy it's it's good fun I
look I don't do it well and it's
frustrating because I can get towed into
a 10-ft wave and surf okay and I look I
don't know how to surf I know how not to
drown so I have a lot of fun but you
know the whole popping up on a surfboard
with a back foot you can't feel and a
knee that you can't bend and and a hand
that's not there to help you push up so
easy it's pretty challenging but you
know I don't do it to stand up I do it
to go out there and have some fun and
hang out with my friends and being the
ocean that's living for me heck yeah man
there's nothing better I I think being
the ocean you do a lot of Surfing I I
used to do way more I I love it man
after Paul told us they're everywhere
I'm probably not going to do it anymore
just come with me because then what's
the chance of someone getting attacked
by a shark with a guy that's been
attacked by a shark I know that's true
Al that's they call that the gambler's
fallacy it can't happen again well of
course it can uh but hopefully they bite
that same hand you're like sucker there
we got so how much stuff are you doing
with shark week and I dude I'm I'm I
couldn't be a bigger fan it's literally
since I was a kid it's been my favorite
week of the year it's like Super Bowl
don't leave the house no I record all of
them I watch them at night but um and we
never had cable I've never had cable we
never had as zako we were too poor so I
had to watch it other ways but it's so
worth just finding out so how's it go
down like I'm always interested how like
you guys film it how far out and they
just save it for the week of Shark Week
like did you film it a year ago and then
they're just saving it for this big week
or how's it worked no we shot we shot at
the start of this year yeah so basically
you have to work around when the sharks
are going to be in the area we watch
sharks you fil first so we didn't we
didn't film in Australia um the show
that I shot this year they filmed in
South Africa and in the Bahamas uh 2
years before that we did Australia so we
did all on the East Coast around New
South Wales around the area that I live
and then down in South Australia where
they do the the cage diving with the
great whites as well and that's all
around the start of the year and and the
shows you shot this year for Discovery
Channel what's the premises what like so
this year's show is called sharks among
us and this crazy awesome Doctor Chris
oconnell created this shark barrier uh
utilizing um magnetic fields and his
goal has been to try and allow humans
and sharks to coexist and by creating
this barrier that that's what he wanted
to do so we have to test it out we got
to find out if this stuff works so know
what better way to test it out than put
it in the water then get in with it so
what does it do it sends out magnetic
waves and the shark look I I don't want
to get too deep into it because I want
people to watch the show and be
surprised because I was blown away that
it actually worked I couldn't blame I'm
thinking no this isn't going to work
it's just some plastic and some magnets
but they know what they're doing You' be
surprised to me what's crazy is like you
spent around 29 years 28 28th year to
come up with this many shark ideas
Concepts I just is there a rider that's
like hey Paul listen sure we think great
whites hate the way hamstrings taste we
need you you know what I'm saying like
how do they they have writers who come
up yeah I'm sure I look I'm mightly new
to this TV stuff so I don't know how it
all works I'm just the guy you just get
a call and they say we want you to be
part of this yeah I'm just the dummy
that gets in the water
well what they have is a production team
right so the people typically who do it
have come up with ideas it and stuff
yeah and well look while we're out there
things change as well and we get to be a
part of it we get to decide what we're
going to shoot and we get to come up
with ideas and try new things and that's
the beauty of it you never know exactly
what's going to happen when you're out
there filming this show I've been on
shows that have started one way and have
totally changed you can't it we have an
endless fascination with those things
that can kill us what I can't wait for
is and maybe they've done this already
is when they attach a small enough but
powerful enough camera to a giant great
white's face and just follow it around
for two years done to want see track it
yeah they've done that but but how good
is the how good is the footage like it's
not very cool it's all right it's like
it's not great a big editing job to
getting better and better it's getting
better but they've done it a ton B they
put but it's on its fin it just like
Falls around Andy that I did my two
shows with did it we put a a fin cam on
a great white in South Australia and
followed around watched it it to the uh
to the gr he has this like he homemade
thing that he created it's just on a a
clamp with a GoPro that has some like
skateboard grip tape on it and you open
it up and it bangs closed shut and then
it has a um I can't remember the metal
it's something that dissolves in water
over a couple of hours and then that
piece of metal dissolves it pulls off
and it has a a VHF receiver on it that's
cool I'm always I always feel bad for
the shark that gets tagged cuz they have
this stupid yellow thing on them around
the other
sharks imagine if I show up with a giant
yellow thing Hing off my air like hey
bro you're not the same as us what are
you doing throwing your outfit off what
the hell's going on here you would paint
it a different color yeah right is it
weird man it's amazing man what what a
what a what a trip what a journey and
that you're still on yeah it's been
crazy it's nice to have this opportunity
actually to be a part of something that
teaches conservation and teaches the
appreciation for some
an animal that you know we're all a bit
scared of sharks people don't even go in
the ocean because of them they
stay yeah but you still love watching
them so it's nice to be a part of that
and try and and share our passion and
our love about them and educate people
like you to know that they're not out
there waiting for us you you can go to
the beach and go swimming and you will
not be eaten by a shark you should be
good what is what is um how is the
conservation effort going how how
endangered are sharks sharks are are
pretty messed up 100 million suck oceans
do suck and it's getting worse and worse
even the Australian government is
allowing coal ports in the Great Barrier
Reef uh we've got a oil mining platform
going down to the Great Australian bite
which is full of marine life it's going
to be put in an area that is so unstable
so rough and it's just a disaster
waiting to happen coral Coral uh coral
reefs are being destroyed at such an
alarming rate in places like the
Philippines and stuff with dynamiting
to get fish and stuff like that right
and and drilling for giant clams and the
commercial fishing is taking all the
fish away from the Reeves so they die as
well I I heard some crazy stat about
tuna do you know how obsessed America is
97% of Pacific Tuna are gone wow
97% from 50 years ago and and also we
are I don't know that they do this
anymore but they would um there's they
take these sort of dragging they're like
the size of a not a super trollers the
size of a semi and they would Troll and
so the bottom of the Atlantic for
stretches as large as Western Europe are
dead zones uh this ecologist was on
there because they would drag and it
takes up everything clams and [__]
everything I mean yeah look if if you
could actually see if we could take the
water out of the oceans or create an
x-ray beam or whatever to see into the
oceans we would stop like that I think
so too it would be a crime to keep
taking fish International
cooperation uh how do you how do you
designate you know sort of fishery free
zones I do think we're doing better
aren't we with um fish farms and stuff I
don't know if those are bad or good but
there's contention on the point there is
contention on the point but we' got to
do something in fact we got to do
something what do you think we should do
you're the guy balls deep in it we we
definitely need to
start instigating some more legislation
into commercial fishing we need to stop
raping the oceans of the fish we need to
stop shark Finning for a start people
feeding shark Finning Finning kill them
for their fin killing them for their
fins watch a great documentary called
shark water shark water will tell you
everything you need to know and that was
made 10 years ago so you can imagine the
state of the oceans now um it's like
it's like the rest of the planet we need
to be put in check we need to take more
control of this or we're going to
destroy the planet we're we're all part
of this um system we're all part of the
ecosystem the circle of life and it is
so out of balance now because there's so
many of us consuming everything in our
path if we keep going we're going to
kill not all the animals but we're going
to kill ourselves as tech technology
over over legislation I think is the
answer because every time you try to
legislate it's so hard to get
International cooperation and people
finds ways around but if you listen to a
lot of these conversations with people
like Sam Harris and and Michael Sherman
all these guys who are kind of like
leading the conversation on what to do
with our future F evolutionary biologist
what's fascinating is that they are now
taking fish and farming them not in the
ocean but in giant tanks uh on land
which is actually showed some promise
they had some they were showing sort of
like difference but also I mean this is
a ways in the
future growing meat without a head which
is what cloning is uh and doing that so
growing meat without a central nervous
system so suffer free meat uh we we
we're doing that with beef we're a long
ways off before it's sustainable
economically and you got to get over the
ick Factor you're bringing in the the
jmi factor as well all that stuff but we
are going to be able to essentially grow
meat the way we do vegetables on land
without a nervous system without a head
and it'll be that actual tissue and the
protein I was listening to that too
they're saying right now for like a
filet it's like
$16,000 like they're nowhere near like I
mean obviously over time we're going to
get this we're all going to be
great whites with two heads so I'll look
forward to that it's not that far away
it really isn't then Shar naido will be
a documentary yeah really well shark
NATO versus OCT Dragon shark Nat's going
to be real my man straight up yeah it's
it's a bit of a worry the and the
ignorance is bliss you know well do you
think it's because they they say we know
more about outer space than we do our
own oceans exactly because we just can't
go there but then you know how far out
into out of space are they talking about
we don't know [__] this we don't know
anything about anything really in the
we're [__] it up yeah exactly right
we do know we're [__] it up and we're
the only ones that can really save it
too we're the only one only conscious
species here to make the changes try and
save the Sharks try and save Shark Week
try I'm stressed why why do you think
there I me obviously we know why there's
a fascination with great whites but
there's never been a great white that
anyone's ever been able to put at
SeaWorld or we saw Asia try putting it
tank they always die yeah it's like one
of the only animals we can't contain as
like a pad or to view I mean do we have
any idea why I have no idea no idea
people talk about me as a shark expert
you know just because I got B by a shark
doesn't make me a shark expert shark we
expert I know stuff I know more than the
average person and I get this knowledge
through friends of mine that I film with
and I work with in conservation and
stuff but I look I'm not an expert I'm
not a scientist I'm not Dr deela sitting
over here in my la it's so true just cuz
you've yeah just just cuz you've had
been on the receiving end yeah it's like
just cuz just cuz you might have gotten
chyia a couple times doesn't mean you're
an expert on Chia you know what I mean
guys what what I know he always made
sexual he's on shark wi oh sorry buddy I
like to bring bring I'm exploring the
subject I'm learning about this is why I
like it as well because I get to learn
and as I learn everyone the watches
shark weake gets to learn as well that's
the beauty of that's exactly right and
do you think Shark Week un UND channel
is helping or hurting the Public's
Persona of of what they think of sharks
no I think it's helping if we didn't
have shark week which is you it's the if
I believe if I'm correct the greatest
amount of viewership in the whole
Year everyone loves it and up for
Discovery Channel
yeah but um everyone loves it you
Everyone likes to learn about sharks
Everyone likes to seen it have you ever
seen a shark have I ever seen one yeah I
I've seen like those I've seen like
those [__] ones with the teeth I've
never seen I've never seen me the
[__] ones the on that that the one
you swam with in the in the tank the
yeah the yeah those suck if it's not a
great wider bull but the thing is it is
so it's actually so rare to see a shark
in the wild so especially if you live
inland and you don't go in the water but
even I've known Surfers that have never
seen a shark in their whole life up
until I got bit I'd been diving for
years I'd never seen a shark it's it's
like seeing a unicorn something
so amazing and beautiful and graceful
and and we keep loving every year more
and more learning about them as the
scientists learn more about them I I
totally think it's helping so let's save
them have you have you had a lot of
shark attack victims reach out to you
not a lot I've had a few yeah I worked
this year with one actually one of the
kids that got bitten in South Carolina
was it bball North Carolina last year
there was you know there was a bunch of
shark bites going on down there and this
kid from Colorado was down there as well
and last year I flew up there and went
and visited him and had a chat what
happened to him he uh had his arm
removed above the elbow and so this year
we got him down to the Bahamas to come
on my show diving with sharks oh nice
yeah was it was another bull shark yeah
we had bull sharks all around us it was
incredible his mom was crapping at dacks
but he was he was all for it Jesus
Tigers the I guess the big three are
tigers bulls and great whites those are
the ones you got to worry about what
about makeo sharks um again you're not
an expert so well I'm not an expert but
you know the quickest shark in the ocean
one of the scarious looking sharks in
the ocean if you ask me but they look
like many great whites they but there's
not too many there's as far as I know
there's no unprovoked attacks from great
from makos you see him having a go at
spear fisherman and stuff sometimes but
you're competing for food you want to
get in the circle of life then that's
your fault yeah let's go to some current
events the cub
the you're a little shark sure why not
I'll take it it's cooler than the C can
we get some more um so I actually think
that you and I may have read the same
article today which one the article on
Vice about um the like the the amount of
energy and money that we put into
mapping space which is a zillion miles
away and has you know given us very
little in terms of return on our
investment meanwhile we have mapped out
a whole 5% of the ocean has so that
means 65% of the of the earth that we
have obviously right here we have no
idea what's going on that is weird so
now that there there's like a big what's
it's called the uh the forum for future
ocean floor mapping was this week it's
like a huge Symposium of scientists and
uh they declared their intentions for a
NASA scale mission to see every last
inch of the seafloor digitally mapped
run by James Cameron yeah that's that's
right James Cameron's on both human
beings are so funny like someone like
what why we go to the Moon cuz it's
there we just have this need to explore
and know everything but we don't have
well hell yeah especially Earth for sure
get on that sooner yeah right I'm yeah
right here man although the ocean is so
crazy vast right what 70% of the earth
okay so we want to go to space you know
that it's pretty vast yeah it's way more
vast than the ocean how long how much
longer how much longer yeah you never
really yeah for sure focus on we're
going have much of a chance much of a
choice if keep doing to this planet what
we're doing we're going to have to go
out there and find another one yeah
that's right how do you stay in shape
you're obviously in really good shape
still yeah I just keep doing the things
that I've always been doing in the
military train hard lift heavy run fast
Right Punch
things good man you signed up at Golds I
said you're in the me for gold yesterday
better it's it's a cool Gym's really hot
in there though it's a funny side effect
of losing limbs you get really hot
really yeah it's weird that's
interesting really yeah someone
explained it to me once that it's
because your skin is your air
conditioning unit and when you lose some
of that your air conditioning uh that
makesense availability goes down so I
get really hot I was sweating my butt
crack off yesterday oh yeah about a hund
do you find uh cuz you're a handsome guy
do you find that yes you're welcome do
you find that you're uh now that you are
an injured man and you got attacked by a
shark are there certain women that are
drawn to that we call them well for you
especially shark
groupies uh shark group yeah look I I do
okay I've been in I've been you got a
couple sardines hanging around I've been
in a relationship for you ongoing
relationships not now recently single
but uh I've been I've been in a
relationship for while now you we'll
talk after the mic were you were you
were you were you married or did you
have a girlfriend before the accident no
no I was I was seeing a girl and we
stayed together for a little while but
you know she wanted to settle down and I
wanted to go and have adventures and
those two things don't always go
together so you know that that ended but
talk about peacocking though when you
walk in a bar you get that Black Hand by
the way I shook his hand and that thing
will crush your hand that that's a
that's a good piece of technology thank
God for smart people H it was up to me
to be peg leg and a hook would you did
you how much say did you have and what
kind of prosthetic you got like is there
how advanced are the Prosthetics now
this is the best in the world as far as
as far as I'm concerned these two
Prosthetics that I have here right now
are the best in the world that are
commercially available they're made by a
German company called Autobook um what
are you able to do with that hand well
look it's to be honest it's a $90,000
holding device uh it opens it closes it
changes grip you know from girl
handshake to man handshake and you know
beer drinking grip um but that that's
what it is you know there's no real
dexterity I can't move the fingers
individually I can press a button on the
wrist unit and then I can like the wrist
goes Germany wave goodbye or whatever
but I don't even know what the
hell
bull I wish people could see this
feature that's a [__] feature you
push a button and it flops so if you
want to wave like a [__] who waves
like that I'm not going to be friend
they got Mercedes that are more complex
than that look at that yeah what the
[__] is that no idea they tight that
hand up Soldier yeah um but it's good
it's good technology it's so much better
than not having one I love I love the
color though cuz most people go with the
flesh color it's [__] the black is
badass you're the first guy I've seen
just rocking the black most people go
with that [__] it's almost like a
pink it might as well look cool badass
and the leg um the leg is also the best
in the world it's as far as I'm aware
it's the only electronic uh leg that's
waterproof as well uh so I can go
swimming with it it's got a running mode
but it doesn't have a running foot so I
can't is that is that uh covered by
insurance or by Veteran Affairs yeah oh
wow so how does that explain how the
Foot Works then it's not the leg I'm I'm
above knee amput so what they actually
call it is a knee it's a prosthetic knee
so I've got the socket on my upper thigh
and then the knee attaches to that and
has a hinge at the top of it and you you
Pro you program it with a computer you
Bond it together via Bluetooth and you
set up how say fast you want the lower
leg to swing through when you're walking
how fast you want it to collapse when
you're going downstairs and sitting down
uh you can set up anti-rip mode you can
make it free swing so you can get on an
exercise bike and and pedal and things
like that you can lock it out in case
you want to do straight-legged leg
raises and things like that but it it it
talks it has six microprocessors in it
an accelerometer a gyroscope it has all
this stuff that I have no idea what it
does but it allows me to walk really
really well if I have long pants on you
would not even know I have a prosthetic
leg do you have to take it off at night
to sleep yeah yeah yeah I you know
that's one of the hassles that you just
have to get used to you know I I got to
get up in the morning and I've got to
put a leg on some people get up in the
morning and they have to find their
motivation or they have to find their
happiness or they have to to find a
reason to keep going or they got to they
get up in the morning they have a
cigarette you know I get up in the
morning I put my leg on I go to the gym
mhm it's it's just life get you going
where do you live uh nowhere at the
moment La now yeah la I just moved here
5 days ago all right good so looking for
a home looking for a car got to do all
this stuff but I'll do that after Shark
Week I'm having too much fun get that
Shark Week Money son you need it here in
La this ain't Australia what do you got
we'll talk our next one we got we're
going to do some uh we'll talk some
politics for a second
here after the one of the definitely the
the worst mass shooting that we've had
in the states in pretty much forever no
it's ever yeah yeah pretty much forever
um the uh the Senate couldn't get enough
bipartisan support to push
through any new laws regarding control
they all got rejected it's not
surprising yeah is that an indication of
how corrupt your government is no little
bit I think it's I think it's in I think
people will blame the NRA and their
lobbying efforts I actually think it's a
philosophical difference I think that
there's vigorous debate on whether or
not there already I think 20,000 laws on
the books when it comes to gun control
that obiously aren't working AR they
well right and so really the biggest if
you really listen to these debates a lot
of the debates are uh we already have
what 400 million guns in circulation so
so I mean if you want to run a massive
confiscation uh effort good luck doing
that in the United States does Australia
have these problems yeah they they were
very effective we had we had uh up until
shooting we had the world's largest um
mass shooting by a single person in like
1987 no it wasn't in a mall it was it
was outside they had an amazing effect
their legislation had an amazing effect
so the prime minister at the time
decided that's it we're going to take
away all semi semi-automatic rifles
putting more legislation and everyone
you know they had a buyback scheme you
get money for your guns and we have not
had a shooting since well like we've had
bikes shooting each other we haven't had
nothing like that Lear from that but the
difference was you guys are too far gone
yeah you guys were able to the they were
also able to pass a a sort of a a
nationwide law the problem in the United
States is there are so many loopholes
because states have their own
sovereignity there are laws like for
example one of the biggest issues is
that as a private citizen in a lot of
States I can sell you a gun and and it's
just a private transaction between us I
don't have to check in on anything that
has to do with your background or
anything and not only that that falls
when you have a gun show in certain
States so if you're a private gun dealer
and you're at a gun show I can buy that
gun from you and I don't have to go
through the the federal what's what's
weird to me is is both sides however you
feel I think we everyone has to
acknowledge whatever we're currently
doing is not working and not only is it
not working it's going terrible I'm I'm
more confused about the uh terrorist
watch list thing where they wanted to
introduce you know more extensive checks
if you've been on a terrorist watch list
or just not allow you to buy a gun and
they knocked that back you want
terrorists to have guns well no but
Americans are very wary it historically
very wary of the idea that because
you're under investigation by a state
agency you are already considered guilty
okay and when you tie in the fact that
you know you're not allowed to have a
gun the idea of having a standing army
in our country was was a very very
contentious issue at in with the SE the
second presidential election in our
country and the the idea being a
standing army is always taken over by a
charismatic leader to suppress the
people that's that's been the history of
Europe and every other country we're not
going to be that way as a country the
Revolutionary War has definely changed
that we had to have an army but we are
we've there's an emotional and
historical quoti you've got to take into
account in this country which is the
idea that and if you hear these debates
man it a lot of people say look if
you're going to pass another gun law
okay is this an idea of people getting
access to to lethal Weaponry probably
but is it also a mental health issue
remember this guy for example in Orlando
had a carrier's permit a regular permit
worked as a security guard for seven
years didn't have really a history of
mental illness he had had two two uh I
guess instances where he was making
inflammatory remarks that were investig
watch list yeah so
so when you start having these debates
the the real issue is what is going to
stop this stuff from happening that's
let's start there without choosing sides
right what what is the what is the idea
how do we keep track of people that are
mentally ill that are exhibiting signs
that they might hurt other people how do
you do that is there a central database
how do you do that without so so so what
is mental illness how do you define
mental illness if I'm depressed is that
a mental illness does that go on my
public record does that affect my
employment these are really questions
that people are wrestling with and you
have to be very careful with how you
define these things because it can it
you're giving someone usually a
government agency power over you that
can have ramifications for the rest of
your life that's all I'm saying you
might punch somebody in the face and
they say you have mental illness because
you have anger issues and you have to go
to anger management like my friend had
to wouldn't be a bad thing didn't shoot
someone it it wouldn't be a bad thing
under certain circum so you go anger
management and I love guns you know I
was a soldier I'm used Bazookas and
rocket launchers and stuff but I've been
here 5 days and I can't get a gun yet
someone under investigation by the FBI
can get one well there's some yeah I
mean here's what I here's what I think
is sensible trained in it I know I I I
just ad I thought a lot about it I don't
know the answer I think it's a lot more
complicated I but we have but I will say
this with every problem there is a
solution and I think that the solution's
out there and I think that we need to I
think both sides are not talking to each
other the debates in this country crack
me up because what happens is we break
up into teams and people get very
emotional go I'm a gun owner I'm an
American [__] you you're a liberal
communist and then the the gun control
people say listen man there's got to be
sensible gun control here and they go
you're [__] infringing on my rights
what's weird where's the person on hey
whatever you believe in it ain't working
what we're doing it's terrible that's
the that's probably most people that's
probably most people but the debate gets
people that make their decisions gets I
find it interesting that people want
more
guns this is how mind this is how you
protect you I've got friends on Facebook
and stuff out here and they they update
their status and say this is how you
stay safe from people with guns make
sure you have a gun with you everywhere
that that seems logical because men do
that W out here you guys haven't changed
since the old spaghetti western movies
well listen listen look at our mythology
our movies go to the movie theater right
now our movies are about they get sh up
well yeah that's by the way but our
movies are about one man who solves his
problems how typically violently John
Wayne it goes back Frontier Justice I
mean Rambo think about the movies think
about Arnold Schwarzenegger and Predator
one man with a gun and those guys are
bad guys g g g g g the the terrorists
there are terrorist over there what do
we do we got to kill them Don joh Donald
Trump Donald Trump basically is calling
for a ban on all Muslims yeah oh let's
get rid of them that's what'll solve the
problem uh and you know so so I think we
have this we have this mindset with two
different camps one mindset is we can't
even Save the Ocean little on gun
there's so many let's move on what else
you got
have speaking of uh speaking of Donald
Trump his campaign is basically broke oh
yeah he's broke as he can change that
with one check his campaign is broke as
[__] he he had three million in
contributions this month which is
already a really low number 2.2 of that
came out of his own pocket I don't know
how much more of his own money but isn't
that the thing though he's not taken no
but he's losing support even from even
from the entire Republican so once again
speaking of FBI investigations his uh
competitor Hillary is she still under
investigation she is she is that blows
me away she might get indicted you're
speaking so you can still run for
president even though so a terrorist can
buy a gun and a suspected criminal can
become president this place is crazy
welcome my friend oh God until proven in
until proven guilty my friend but that
is something that people have talked
about first of all if you were anybody
but Hillary Clinton you'd be in jail
when you when you have a an an internet
server that you put in your bathroom and
it's and and you're the Secretary of
State people have access to those those
emails that is something that if you're
a regular guy and you work for the
government you're a CIA operative you're
going to jail jail so how does she
bypass this you know just keep on keep
it on man especially when you're running
against the dumbass Donald Trump we like
we I mean out of the two we'll take that
it's not that bad that's what we're
doing these is it the lesser of two
evils here at the moment cuz you can
have Trump you know if we have Trump
we're ala I when I first heard that I no
[__] thought it was a joke n politics
Trump I thought I actually thought it
was a joke until it started going
further I was like holy
crap and I thought he oh he won't make
it very far especially with all these
racist things he said you know kept it
kept going on so now it's down to the
lesser of the two evils and some people
firmly believe in Hillary and some
people violently so far ahead of him at
this point and
his own and they've tried to to him and
I'll do a dropping knowledge on Trump
because I actually I have that's what I
had today that we'll have a little talk
real quick about it but let's let's go
to the next thing we'll dive that was it
my man okay so so my dropping knowledge
on Trump and I just wanted to kind of
give people an idea let's just talk for
a second about the wall he keeps talking
trying to build he was talking about
this on Sunday uh so he thinks building
a wall is going to keep all those
terrible Mexicans out and all those all
those terrible Latin Americans who you
know are obviously coming in and ruining
our country etc etc a well that would
caus by conservative estimates $40
billion he also said that Mexico is
going to pay for it okay good luck
getting Mexico to pay for Vincente Fox
who is the who was the former president
basically said go [__] yourself you're
not going to get a proud country like
Mexico to pay $40 billion nor should we
and then he went further and said well
then we'll OS tariffs on Mexico and we
will confiscate money that Mexicans make
in this country and send back to their
families which of course is illegal and
of course unamerican and of course crazy
okay can you just clarify something for
me as a foreigner yeah what's wrong with
Mexicans nothing nothing they lot to
they work their ass off they've been so
nice they doob they do jobs most white
people or whoever whatever ethnic are in
America don't want to do yeah and I
would remind people that they Mexicans
what do we how do you define a mexic
there are a lot of Mexican-American
citizens that are a great part of the
fabric of this country etc etc that's
what I figured he he went so far as to
say he's being indicted and I want to
just go through what a great businessman
he was his casinos dead defunct uh were
a disaster Stakes he had an airline dead
even they've done some studies in the
New York Times about his real estate
Ventures doesn't made a lot of
miscalculations a lot people in City
Bank and the banks loaned them the money
uh a lot of those Bankers were fired a
lot of the banks went broke you're
dropping knowledge how shitty Trump is
yeah but we keep going for a sec uh he
even said that the judge who is
investigating his essentially College
Trump University the judge should be
recused because he's Mexican well he's
ethnically Mexican but he was born in
Indiana and they were like but dude he
was born in Indiana he's an American you
saying because of his eth ethnicity this
is the big dropping knowledge though so
just we we've already got we' already
got how crazy through this Trump stuff
no no this is important I want to
address how he talks about Muslims and
how we should ban Muslims from this
country let's just examine this very
just from a just from a very very
important just from a very sort of let's
just take it from a strategic point of
view take all the emotion out of
it if you ban Muslims from this country
if you are serious about fighting
terrorism overseas and there is a
terrorist threat there is an extremist
Islamic terrorist threat we know that
exists guess who you need you need you
need the help of the countries that are
hosting those people those countries are
Muslim we could never do it without
Muslim cooperation ever so strategically
anybody in the CIA anybody in the front
lines of this fight will tell you how
absolutely nuts that is to actually
create an enemy of 1 B300 million milon
Muslims it makes no strategic sense
forget the emotion so that's kind of
since we were talking about Trump I got
to drop an knowled on you'll enjoy this
all right so um in the past 88 years
there's 100 this is in California where
we live there's 114 confirmed shark
attacks just 10 were fatal so uh it's
about one attack each year on average
and think about all the millions of
people that are in the be that go to the
ocean so there they're basing it from
basically San Diego to San Francisco uh
1100 miles of Coast huge right so it
sounds like a low probability um the
hottest spots for shark attacks by
County um are San Diego with 17 Humbolt
Monterey Santa Barbara Marin St Louis
abiso um Santa Cruz then Los Angeles is
six San Francisco's five so these are
non fatal non fatal shark non fatal
shark attacks yeah but uh have we had
shark bites in Los Angeles besides I
think there was one cuz the guy got
caught up in but also the the shark taxs
go down certain months which that
doesn't matter on these odds because uh
July through October the beaches aren't
as busy it's saying but um so it says uh
a Stanford study reports the risk of a
shark attack is down 91% since
1950 however here's your droping
knowledge the actual number of tax has
increased every decade since
1960 which so is the population yeah
well that's what but that's what this
this is the argument is they're saying
the reason they went up is cuz we're
doing more activities in the ocean it's
not like sharks are attacking More
Humans so this this uh this Bas this
article is kind of Honey [__] people
saying that the shark attacks are up but
they're actually down overall with the
amount of people in the oceans and if
you listen to the scientist the
population of sharks has actually gone
down so it's it' be interesting to look
into why uh the sharks biting people
more frequently if there's less of them
around are they hungry are they looking
for food have we taken all of their food
you know are we populating areas that we
previously didn't populate that sharks
have been hunting in before there's so
many factors involved in it's like
everything else we've been discussing
today it's so bloody complicated Well
here here's one for you and this is uh
from basically 10 years 20 2010 there
are
114,000 accidental deaths in California
alone uh 40, th000 of these was because
of driving right so that number one is
driving uh 30,000 involve uh drug
overdose so again not animals 18 were
due to this is weird just
Falls people [__] them F and five
were from Shark death in California even
taking selfies are responsible for more
deaths it's true I don't know how that
happens they fall off
cliffs yeah cuz they take off they fall
off cliffs really so you could just make
another whole subsection created with
human stupidity yeah and that would
completely eradicate even
your guy who had the shotgun there was a
rattlesnake and the guy took the shotgun
and go and and jammed its head with his
with the of the yeah and the the r like
ah and wrapped his thing around the
trigger Kachi pulled boom blew his head
off and his butd half of a buddy's face
off
[__] snake laugh he we got this thing
know rattlesnake said enjoy this Victory
with one [__]
eye Jesus man not a good time uh let's
go to fan questions Evan the
moo cuz he's all muscle and super
aggressive if you get into his food
well compared to the other shos are
pretty giant makos
get the shark guy over a th000 PBS but
makos compared to Great Whites Bull and
tigers smaller makos are bigger than
Bulls makos would be about same size as
Bulls they about generally about 9t I
think I think they can get a little bit
bigger but as far as great o big shark
those things and it's not even like you
can talk about a great white shark and
say oh yeah it's 15 16 foot it's the
girth yeah that's the thing when you see
these I like the
wayth yeah but he said the of these
sharks skinny they're not skinny yeah
they're so fatting around especially
what they call the The Supergirls and
these things are just dinosaurs they
don't even need to be pregnant they're
just huge I'd love to see one we got we
got an offer to do an Australia live
tour oh yeah the only way I'm going is
if we can jump in the water with sharks
do it in a cage yes the only place to do
it is in South Australia did you say
helmet I don't know if that's going to
help and a full body sumo suit and what
do we got for makos how big are they I
want to know 12 foot it's about let's
see here it's not going to matter you'd
have to have the top five largest sharks
the average adult measures around 10 ft
in length and weighs from 132 to 298 lb
yeah they've had some big 12 foot ones
so the big the biggest shark obviously
great well it's not that big biggest
shark is whale
shark uh great white probably tiger
shark or you got bosing shark as well
yeah they're giant whale sharks and all
but the Great White's the king daddy man
oh it is except um I got you right here
unless it's being hun I got you right
here so B the makos aren't in the top 10
really no a sizewise you mean no not
just Spade fastest one they're fast
skinny yeah uh obviously you're whales
number one basking number two Baskin
look ridiculous I'm not too scared of
that thing at all uh number three great
white number four tiger shark and number
five Pacific sleeper shark doesn't sound
scary at all having the opportunity six
Greenland shark seven Hammerhead not
very scared of hammerheads I feel like
they so well that's what we did we've
dived with great Hammerheads in the
Bahamas this year and I'd never seen one
before they are the most incredible
looking sharks like so hugely evolved
and because they have the eyes on the
side of their head and we got this
briefing from Craig o conell before we
got in the water they will actually swim
directly into you cuz they can't see
they can't see they detect but they
can't see you with the eyeballs so you
have to grab them by their gigantic bony
hard head and redirect them that's not
the easiest thing to do when you only
have one hand either cuz you got to make
sure you're grabbing it by the middle or
it just sort of like turns in on your
hand but they're so incredible to see
and they're massive too and they're not
that dangerous right no they don't
attack humans I'll tell you who I'll
tell you who's not hearing a peep out of
any of those [__] sharks and I mean
not a peep the old old Orca oh yeah
or orcas laugh at gray whites and false
killer whales you didn't know there's
false killer whales as well what do you
mean so they look a lot like killer
whales but they don't have the Black and
White markings they're gray and we just
had a guy an amateur drone flyer um get
footage of I think it was three false
killer whales chasing down and killing a
great white shark Jesus Christ yeah so
they got it all filmed from above how
they they come up underneath him in the
stomach like Dophin they chased it down
I think they must have woree it out a
little bit and then you just see this
white Flash and it's the shark
Underside up facing towards the camera
and it's basically got it like a dog
does a bone you can see the great white
out either side of its mouth I got to
see this where is this footage it should
be on YouTube called a flash whale just
just Google just Google um false killer
whal false killer wh whar that is that
what it's called a false killer wh false
killer that's the scient killer wh right
yeah no it's not it's a false killer wh
it's the same same sort of thing it's
like you know they're all um can't think
of the word of it now but same sort of
family it looks it looks like a killer
whale but spray painted gray exactly
yeah it's undercover L Orca ain't here D
peep that's the one yeah four of them
hold get that over here bring it over
here right now is this on Shark Week
bring that over here right freaking now
that's his drone look at look at Mr look
at the great white uh El great white
looks like [__] next to these things
holy [__] you can see it holding do we
know that's a gray white though yeah oh
my god dude dude that thing dominated
that little great white not scared great
whites anymore they said when when we
were shooting down in South Australia
they we were on a boat last year where
we were using sound to attract the
sharks in because they didn't have uh
licenses to blood and bait so they came
up with this ingenious way to attract
the great whites in by using um low low
dulcet tones like death metal and they
the Sharks would come in it was really
incredible um because it it mimics the
low sounds of um fish and you know
injured and flopping on the surface and
seals bumping into each other I guess
but they accidentally played I don't
know if it was accidentally or not but
they wanted to see what happened and
they played the sound of
orcas and the Sharks pissed off for 3
months damn three months months or are
the badasses of the SE yeah they are
yeah I had noide I I mean I knew they
badass we call them the big dogs of the
sebr big dogs call the big dogs the
alpha males I call them the big dogs
when I see orcas Kings King Kings of the
Waves I go here come I go here come the
big dogs that's what I say see I say
king of the Waves you say king of the
Waves King of the waves but I don't know
if they're in the waves a lot oh they in
the waves seen him kill the seals they
they make him goate the wave and rock
off the call King of the Waves King of
the Waves cuz they what they do is they
put on land and just grab cuz I'm
usually in deep water so I call them the
big dogs King of the Waves okay good
Lord let's do some fan question
hour two we start getting talking about
nothing all right first fan question
Paul did you have any feelings of
revenge against the sharks or were you
able to put it in perspective right away
no I never had any feelings of Revenge
right when it happened you weren't like
no not even a little bit man I lived a I
lived a dangerous life you know I was
jumping out of planes with the army with
a machine gun and running around the
bush jumping out of helicopters and
blowing up bombs and shooting guns all
that I I chose a dangerous life cannot
blame your choice of Life your the
things that happened to you because of
your choice of life I knew there was
sharks in there it sucked but I sign up
did you do any did you do any training
in the Northern Territory do you have
any contact with crocodiles no I've been
up there I've seen them they're pretty
impressive they're pretty horrifying oh
yeah but uh I would I would much rather
deal with sharks than Crocs 100% cuz you
never hear anyone going yeah the it's
weird man The Croc they don't like the
way I taste they just scar of my arm n
they love had a girl get eaten a couple
weeks ago you you guys had a girl yeah
yeah they they went swimming in a
waterway that was sign posted as having
crocodiles at night listen girl you got
to look they're probably drunk [__]
drunk uh no I think she was probably
late 20s I'm not 100% drunk yeah just
decided to go for a swim I think it was
in Northern Queensland it wasn't even in
in Northern this I thought you said
Mexico no no this is in Australia I just
decided to go for a swimming night in
Northern Queensland no you don't got
eaten friend jumped in and got bit as
well we get tourists up there a lot so
one got eatat and one got bit yep they
are scary crocodiles and they won't just
just bite you and let go they'll bite
you they'll flip and they'll they'll do
the death roll trying to twist you to
pieces trying to kill you then they'll
stick you under a log tend yeah so you
decomposed and they'll come back and
atat you yeah that's scary they might be
the scarest animal I would agree with
you it's literally it's not you know
sharks they're a little confused they
might bite you let go
crocodil plot and they learn they'll
watch people coming up to the water to
collect their their daily water rations
and things like that and they'll time it
they'll know what time I I saw a video
where it said uh careful alligators on
the opposite side of this fence show the
alligator climbing the fence oh yeah oh
yeah Rogan posts on instagam shows this
alligator giant tail oh cool we're on
the other side nah I like it over here
though cling the fence what it was it
was it was like in Jurassic Park where
the Raptor figures out how to open doors
it was exactly like that with an
alligator his tail to problem himself
big alligator
oh the chaining fence that's not good
chain link fence always look for the
nostres all the little nostrils and
those nostrils I'm out is that a log
[__] no any Costa Rica remember in Costa
Rica we on this and the thing is you
they're not just in the water like
sharks are it's not like okay I'm scared
of sharks I'm not going to go in the
ocean the crocodiles go on land we've
had them in the ponds at golf courses I
know they end up Gators end up in
swimming pools don't they down in
Florida course they of course they you
can't escape them do anything you can
run away from them because they're not
that quick straight Australia has you
have these tiger snakes brown snakes you
have snakes that will bite you taipans
Bush Masters I think you got snakes
that'll bite you that you we'll see you
later you got K [__] face you got the
funnel web spiders Bo box your face off
you seen kangaro go to work unless our
boy hurricane from we we just did
Ridiculousness with Rob jerck and his
buddy hurricane his name is David he's a
giant giant guy he's about uh 68 and 300
and some odd Pals giant man even bigger
and I said and I sang a song to him I
went uh he's so big that wild animals
are afraid of him and I was doing this
thing and he goes actually I had a wolf
and a kangaroo submit to me wow and I
was like what he goes yeah there's this
place the sanctuary I've actually my
family I've been there and uh this
kangaroo saw him and usually will they
show you their balls they pull their
balls out for real that's a thing I
don't that I learn something about my
own country when he saw him the kangaroo
put his balls back in they go oh he's
being submissive to you the wolf that
comes out Timberwolf comes out and rolls
over on its back said he's going to
submit you're much bigger but but these
are also but these aren't wild like you
put Hurricane's ass in a real Australian
[__] setting that K and go huh I
don't know
douch you know you know what's not
hearing a peep at from Hurricane or
anybody on two two legs no is the is
it's a bird and it's not a c give me it
oh man those things they got the like
big claw on their leg they got the big
bone on their head that will kick you
you don't know [__] you [__] excuse
me tell this [__] your [__] ears
they they're like a velociraptor in thew
that comes out they will kick you and
the sliced open stomach f are they as
big as ostrich yeah they're big they're
thicker shut up they got that big big
blue neck big front claw tell this
[__] that will kick you and open you
up you guys are scared of him in
Australia we're scared of him we just
you don't see him anywhere yeah but if
they if you do you [__] you run R you
your M CL a tree sorry I had to go B on
him we [__] caught him oh yeah oh no
dude they jum in the and your ABD he's
using a shield why the [__] is that guy
so close to he's using a shield they're
untamable you cannot tame a cur even in
the zoos they have to be put behind 7
foot fences Jesus Christ so a little
respect for the
casu don't seen that that thing looks
stupid dude I like that false killer uh
what else you got EV all right uh next
fan question we've got is from Alexander
28 what is the biggest change in your
life since the shark
attack [__] there's been so many uh
initially obviously not having a hand
and a
leg that's it's a pretty big change I
think yeah kind of a big change you
don't realize how much you use your hand
and leg until you lose it not being you
know that really messes up your ability
to squat and bench press um luckily I
have tools for that now so but uh you
know everything has changed every aspect
of my life has changed I've become a
different person you know like I said I
was scared of sharks in public speaking
now I make shark documentaries and do
motivational speaking so my career's
changed my mindsets changed well it
hasn't my mindset hasn't changed just
developed further yeah well you left
right-handed there you go I'm
left-handed now yeah that makes a huge
difference learning to write left-handed
learning how to how to do things
one-handed how do you open a can with
one hand I don't know how do you use a
dust pan and broom how do you tie your
shoelaces All These Little Things how do
you do up buttons and do your ties and
all these little things you got to
relearn how to do and they're so
frustrating until you just learn cuz you
have no other choice yeah you don't have
a choice and it's amazing what you can
do when you don't have a choice that's
crazy never jerked off with my left hand
sorry to say that but that is
significant sorry I mean come on go
there with our boy look I'm just saying
it's it's it's difficult I was having a
chat with um Jon Jones at the uh LA
Fitness Expo when I was up here like 6
months ago you know the first question
he asked me he checked off with that
robot hand I was like [__] John I'll let
you I'll let you get away with that one
question of all the questions yeah at
least that was my last com after two
hours what else you got have but it is
significant all right and no I haven't
I'm too scared it's going to clench up
and rip the skin off malf you felt how
hard that squeezes yeah I felt how hard
it was turn dick like a fruit roll what
else you got since the attack have you
gained a new respect for the odd and
dangerous sea as it's clearly a
different world than we have appear here
on land no I always I always had that I
was a Navy man so you KN you already
knew what you were setting up for waves
and current that you also worry about
right waves and currents and sea States
and box jellyfish and blue ringed
octopus and all all that St this blue
ring octopus is Big the most deadly
octopus in the world why you say that
because they kill you how big are they
they can be about the's finest talk to
the I know about these but go ahead I'll
let him go go so they can be as small as
a quarter quarter and they can still
kill you still kill you yep and you just
find them in rock pools and little kids
will pick them up and put them in their
hand and M look I found an octopus and
it can kill you yeah are you kidding me
[__] why it's just poison yeah it's
poison got Venom [__] poison never heard
of it yeah so C blue ring octopus why
don't they do a blue ring blue ring
Octopus Week thing sounds terrifying
that'd be sick that's bad I didn't know
they were in little I didn't know I
didn't know they were in pools well no
[__] that thing's killer look at
anything that beautiful is killer if
it's spotted anything with those colors
and Spott the thing is that until it
feels threatened you can't even see the
blue rings on it okay it just looks like
a normal Little Octopus little I love
octopus I would grab that I love octopus
what now does it bite you or is it the
skin bites you it bites you with its
little beak beak yeah and injects a
poison in oh [__] yeah they're really
really venomous SC there's a lot of are
those only in Australia as far as I'm
aware yeah I I haven't heard of them
being anywhere else perfect yeah just
another one to add to the list yeah
don't weigh there's too many ways to die
in well you know when I was in besides
gun by man yeah that's true that's true
I was in Tahiti and they had uh the
Scorpion or stone fish stone fish and
they look like stones and my kids
what's that I put my hand on one Those
are nasty it's painful so ugly they are
what else you got to have all we got one
more being an expert is there any true
fear Jus to justify uh being scared of
sharks while playing in the oceans I
know sharks are brutal but lightning is
dangerous too given the chance so would
you say that shark encounters are more
fate and Randomness or should these two
kids keep their tasty asses out of the
water well firstly clarify once again
not an expert um but I man I never stop
doing something I love because of the
things I'm afraid of sure you never stay
out of the water because you're scared
of drowning or anything like that man
don't worry about that life will hand
you what it's going to hand you just
enjoy yourself live your life more
afraid of not living than I am of dying
but there are are also ways for you to
avoid being eaten by a shark stay up to
you know stay up to date on current
events you know check with yourself stay
on land stay on land if you're a big
swim dust dust or Dawn right well you
know there's contention on that point as
well because a lot of shark attacks have
happened in the middle of the day um
don't swim near the mouths of rivers if
you're swimming near uh peers where
people are fishing obviously people
catching fish and the fishes flopping
around are going to attract so why not
near mouths of rivers because that's
where the bull sharks go in and out of
because they're the only shark that can
live in fresh water and salt water so
they go up the rivers and they pop so
that there's no threats to the lives of
their their baby bull sharks so you know
you I grew up thinking that the rivers
were safe well dude when we were in they
also don't say don't wear shiny stuff
yeah shiny stuff is going to make you
look like food when we were in Costa
Rica um of times first of all the mouth
of the river was as he said just uh 300
Kil meters just down that way so I was
like that's already a huge problem
second of all the crocodiles come out
and they Beach on the beach they're on
the beach they're 20 Footers on the
beach now apparently they don't bite you
in Open Water I don't believe you and
I'm not getting in that especially
saltwater crocodiles couldn't be anymore
now just because it's never been done
doesn't mean it's not going to happen
that's right and my kids are frolicking
around the water I was like nah I don't
like this I was right with them looking
as if I'm going to do anything by the
way still though personal responsibility
sometimes it's fate sometimes it's
unlucky sometimes it's ignorance
sometimes you just got to chalk it up as
you were the we're all going to die
we're all going to die we know what a
better way to go than by a crocodile or
shark yeah Le you have a good story in
heaven you're make CNN at least yep big
deal out here well is there any more of
that's it my man boom where can they
find you brother if people want to watch
learn more about you website Twitter all
that I've got a website pa.com I'm going
to be on shock weake all week um on
Facebook Instagram Twitter all that
stuff just like everyone else on the
planet is and what's your uh handle on
Instagram or Paul De Gilda boom nice and
simple and the book is no time for fee
you can get it online bet your sweet ass
there's no time for
there some really good surgery photos in
there too I've had when I do my
motivational talks I've been doing it
for about 4 years now I've had 43 people
pass out what no [__] 30 39 men you
bring them up you bring up yeah and I
give I give a fair warning I give a big
uh screen to say you know graphic photos
coming up I make very ligh heart of it
as well you I have a bit of fun with it
I give everyone a warning you know if
you if you don't like blood and guts
just you know go to a happy place close
your eyes I'll let you know when it's
all over but then someone told me that
they passed out just because of the way
I was explaining it well blood you know
I've had I I had a girlfriend who would
faint at the sight of her own blood and
she did it on twice she got she she she
got like nicked like yes she got uh yes
yes and she she if you were messed up
have some fun I'll tell you who it is
after you know and uh we were standing
there and she she nicked herself cut
herself uh and with on a knife and she
went I looked over and I just heard just
and she was out on the floor I was like
holy [__] I couldn't believe it just
passed out well Paul we appreciate you
coming on man it's such inspirational
story you're uh you're one of the good
guys man we got your back brother thanks
a lot for coming grab a brew hell yeah
cuz you're in our you're our neigh and
we'll talk about this ocean what the
hell the three of us can do to fix it
this is the final kid we're out